all right the boys season two episode
seven things happen
gonna give you the spoiler warning right
now for this video because things happen
and people are dying
it's like there's so many people this
season they were like yeah we know
we introduced them last season but this
is season two my friends they've been
around long enough gonna talk about it
right now so
john noble is butcher's dad amazing
because
if butcher's gonna have a dad it's gotta
be denithore right and just like that
rohan and gondor were bound by blood
and in terms of plot well starlight's
out of the group
now i mean homelander live on television
was like yeah so
she's working with the people who killed
translucent so she's
she's not in the cool club anymore so
that's permanent like that's a thing
that's
that happened guess she's gonna have to
hang out with them in that dingy ass
basement
she's living large now saw more noir
also learned he has a nut allergy
i mean i know from the comment section i
mean
things get spoiled in the comment
sections wish it didn't happen but it
happened
so i know who noir is in the comic books
so is that consistent is the nut allergy
new
that's what i'm trying to say homelander
in this episode was a dick though like
i guess you can be a complete smarmy
narcissistic
dick and i'm like yeah but you haven't
hit full dick yet threaten to laser an
entire plane of people and then leave
and let them die
not full dick yet you snatch a kid from
his loving mom
now you're full dick i just didn't like
it yeah i mean i didn't like the passive
aggressive [ __ ] he was doing you know he
just kind of shows up with storm front
like what's she gonna do
really get mad all right well she can
shoot lightning and he can
just snap this whole house in half
that's a scary shitty situation for her
to be in so right there
you know just for them being there i was
like i made my skin crawl tell the kid
hey your mom lied to you and snatched
him and took him off and that's that
they did bring one thing up that i
didn't even think about
is that that kid is the first
born superhero it wasn't really made he
was
he's just the product of a superhero
being his father i don't think about
that i guess that is a pretty big deal
still feel bad for becca butcher damn so
she's got kano in her corner so
he'll make it right can we talk about
the fact that vaat has shitty security
all right so they bring
lamplighter or actually lamplighter
bring they break into vod first of all
the fact that they just got in through
this little vent on the street level
that's pretty shitty security but second
of all lamplighter's handprint still
works to
open locks and doors like he still has
security clearance i thought huey was
walking into a trap because there's no
way lamplighters
no way he would still have security
clearance i've worked at
retail companies retailed like you know
much
smaller than vot in which when an
assistant manager leaves or gets fired
or something their first order of
business
is to change the security code or at
least deactivate theirs but lamplighter
still has security clearance someone got
fired even if lamplighter technically
still worked for vot when he was
incinerating people in that
cd ass hospital still i feel like
someone
up there would be like so you mean he's
not working in this building great we'll
just go ahead and take away his
handprint security clearance it just
seems so easy and it wasn't a trap which
means
people at vat are just stupid and then
yeah he just burns himself to death and
he dies
which is a bummer because i thought he
was pretty compelling no he's dead now
that's what you get for being compelling
then they're at this courtroom and vots
gonna get raked over the coals the
scientist
who made homelanders there turns out it
was all a
red hearing yeah heads popped heads
popped everywhere just heads were just
popping it was just
it was a massacre it was a bloodbath and
is it that one soup you know the super
magneto
sith soup which people were like jeremy
i can't believe you didn't think of 11
from stranger things well i didn't
jack from mass effect that was actually
my initial thought it's possible but
it seems easy it's like obviously that's
the only
suspect we have that's able to do that
though i don't know why in that one
episode like
the fbi agent lady when her head popped
everyone else was there all the boys
were wife was just like ah
papa pop all of them taken out it's fine
now i don't know maybe it'll make sense
next week maybe it won't but i was
actually impressed with the fact that a
lot of things happened this week the
longest
lasting other than the heads popping the
longest lasting thing is the fact that
starlight's
no longer in the seven unless she can
clear her name but the court of public
opinion is gonna
they're gonna be like yeah well [ __ ] her
then which the public opinion
social media thing i feel like there's
there are mixed messages in this show at
least this season of this show so at the
beginning of this episode
stormfront's essentially you'd think
she's on a campaign trail i mean it's a
whole campaign trail to get
more soups made so we need more compound
v she's saying things like you know this
many illegal immigrants coming to
america how many of them could be super
terrorists also she says we need to keep
america safe again but okay so that's
stormfront
but then they did a thing they brought
homelander
publicly on the trail with her the
problem with that is there's no real
social media backlash on well either
stormfront or homelander
but really for the sake of my argument
there's no backlash on homelander and
there would be earlier in the season you
saw homelander kind of take a hit you
know people were pressing him and he
fantasized about just laser eyeing all
of them and so now after taking a hit
his answer is well i'm going to go out
there
on this campaign trail which is
essentially
their parallel for right-wing ideology
in the show
essentially that is the show's angle
that's what they're doing in the show so
after he takes a public hit their answer
is to send him out there and do a thing
that would essentially
divide his fan base anytime someone
chooses a hard slide on a hot button
topic it divides a fan base so
homelander who never
seemed largely hated he seemed like
captain america superman everyone loved
him has now
chosen a side on a hot button topic in
the world of the boys
which there would definitely be social
media backlash
and not just social media backlash
business backlash because he works
in the entertainment industry that's
what starlight says in this episode
she's like
everything we do is just it's all
[ __ ] it's all for money because it's
the entertainment industry it's a thing
i've liked about the boys
problem is the entertainment industry is
largely
left-wing but what homelander and
stormfront are
essentially campaigning for is the
writers of the show doing their parallel
on right wing so now you've made
homelander publicly
hardcore right wing in the show which
means there would be a lot of blue
checkmark entertainment industry twitter
backlash
on homelander and in a world of the boys
where it's thus
far been all about social media and
public perception the fact that
we just haven't seen any backlash is
weird what talk show hosts
trevor noah stephen colbert they're
gonna see
homelander out there with stormfront
saying these things they're gonna be
like
nothing to joke about here it's just
weird it makes the universe feel
inconsistent anyhow those are my
thoughts on today's episode and that
brings us to the sponsorship segment of
this video i want to thank the sponsor
of this video this video is brought to
you by postmates postmates is a food
delivery app
tons of restaurants around you use
postmates to deliver food right to your
door you can watch the whole process
from order pick up delivery
all in real time they do contact free
delivery the driver can just drop the
food off right at your porch then bounce
you never even have to see them and
today yes i ordered food from the same
family-owned indian restaurant i did
last time did i order chicken korma
again yes i did but also ordered some
naan bread because
much more appealing on camera than korma
also
tastes good too so just enter the code
you see on screen five off john's to get
five dollars off your first two delivery
orders of 15
or more also friendly reminder the offer
expires 10 days from the promo code
redemption so keep that in mind so click
the link below support your local
family-owned restaurants in these tough
times and thank you once again to post
mace for sponsoring this video
i do appreciate it alright so the boys
season 2 episode 7 just one episode to
go
wow what did you think of it whatever
you thought comment below let me know
and as always if you like what you've
seen here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
[Music]
you